لماذا يصف شخص ما بعد إزالة ورم في المخ
الأمر بأنه ممتع لأن
كريستينا فايد غنت خلال عمليتها،
أحد عواطف كريستينا هو الغناء الذي
تحب القيام به الكاريوكي لذلك فكرنا
لماذا لا نجعلها تغني
[موسيقى]
لمعرفة المدى الذي ستصل إليه إزالة
أنسجة الورم  يوضح الغناء أن
جراحها الدكتور نيتيش باتيل في
المركز الطبي بجامعة جيرسي شور كان بحاجة إلى أن
تكون كريستينا مستيقظة وتتحدث حتى
يتمكن من معرفة في الوقت الفعلي أي تأثير
للجراحة التي كان يجريها على دماغها
[موسيقى]
فكيف اخترت قائمة التشغيل التي
تريدها  أعلم أنه من المضحك أننا بدأنا مع
بعض من نيل دايموند
ثم أعتقد أن كريستينا لم تكن تعرف
الكثير من كلمات الأغاني لذا انتقلت
إلى خياراتها وكان خيارها المفضل
هو الموسيقى التصويرية من فيلم موانا من ديزني، وهذا
ليس مفاجئًا لأن كريستينا تعلم
الأطفال الصغار
الغناء  أفضل من
المحادثة المستمرة، يمكنني أيضًا اختبار إيقاعها
وإيقاعها، وقالت كريستينا لمجلة
نيوزويك إنه كان الأمر كما لو كنت أقيم
حفلتي الموسيقية الصغيرة للجميع
قرب نهاية العملية حيث
بدأنا نلاحظ بعض الأخطاء في
غنائها، وهي إشارة إلى أن ذلك سيكون محفوفًا بالمخاطر.
لإزالة المزيد من الأنسجة، كان تشخيصها
جيدًا في غنائها "
جراحة حلوة" بابتسامة جينيمو لقناة سي إن إن نيويورك